yes I think we can all agree on the real
hero hard not to see it that way
there's been the honor of my life to
work with the men and women behind me
today it's about the heart James who
drove good and Joe in the integrity of
rape fight birth and the courage of Lou
Alvarez and the tenacity of John feel
they they lifted this 9/11 community on
their shoulders and they carried them
home and I will always be so proud to
have been associated with it and we can
never repay all that the 9/11 community
has done for our country but we can stop
penalizing them and today is that day
that they can excel because
unfortunately the the pain and suffering
of what these heroes continue to go
through is going to continue we've been
to many funerals to many hospices these
families deserve better and I'm really
I'm hopeful that today begins the
process of being able to heal without
the burden of having to advocate and I
will follow you whatever your next
adventure Shelby
[Applause]